[Music]
hey guys we are so excited to announce
we are producing our own original
content head over to the trendy for the
best DIYs fashion tips makeup hacks and
so much more we are sure you're going to
love it and be sure to let us know what
you think in the comment section we've
all been out of loose ends with nothing
to do at some point in our lives most of
the time we try to distract ourselves
whether it's by watching the show
reading a book or doing something but
today you'll see how some people had
lots of time on their hands and did some
pretty weird stuff make sure you watch
to the end to see what one YouTube star
did to his brother's bedroom if you
haven't visited us before be sure to
give this video a big thumbs up and
remember to subscribe to our Channel
today we're looking at 10 people who had
way too much time on their hands 10 all
the world's a tip when you were a child
did your parents tell you not to play
with your food ours did however this
person who found themselves at a bit of
a loose end use their food to come up
with something that will admit is pretty
awesome
what they did was to create a map of the
world made entirely of ridged potato
chips and it's not a rough amalgamation
that might just potentially look like an
atlas either no everything is in the
correct proportion and is pretty much
the right shape to think of the world's
island nation whether it's the United
Kingdom Iceland or even Madagascar they
are there in edible form the smaller
land masses are made up from crispy
crumbs while the larger continent are
made from a multitude of potato chips
while we think this is amazing it's the
sort of thing that raises questions like
are the different parts of the world
made from different flavors could they
have made this map and had the same
effect if they had used plain tips what
about if they had used tortilla chips or
popcorn does it matter what sort of
ridge tip you use or is there only one
specific brand that works and didn't
this person have something else they
could have done instead regardless this
made us laugh and some
and it could possibly be used as an
educational tool so the crisp lover who
made this we salute you 9 banana man
strikes again we all like a delicious
piece of fruit it's tasty and it's good
for you too
but one thing all fruit lovers are all
too aware of is how you need to eat that
fruit pretty quickly the very last thing
that you want is for your yummy
foodstuff to go off that means it'll
become mushy tastes horrible and be
pretty much inedible and one of the most
sensitive bits of fruit we can think of
is the banana those things go from
lovely to nasty pretty quickly so not
only is it important to eat them up
before they go off you'll want to turn
them into sculptures quickly what was
that you want to know why you turn them
into sculptures well we're not entirely
sure why but a man he does is Japanese
artists Kazuki Yamada mr. Yamada turns
an inconspicuous piece of fruit into a
xenomorph from the alien film's Darth
Vader from the Star Wars franchise even
a pretty cool-looking shark what's even
better is that he doesn't do it
full-time during the day he works as an
electrician but by night he creates his
awesome artwork he uses a toothpick and
spoon to gouge out the bits of bananas
that he doesn't need and mold it into
what his imagination comes up with and
the craziest thing is that he has 30
minutes to make the sculpture before the
banana goes off mr. Yamada
we salute you eight a watcher in the
bathroom we hope we don't need to tell
you how to use bathroom paper well not
how to use bathroom paper in the way
that it was made to be used but someone
must have had to spend a lot of time in
the restroom to come up with this next
one have you ever heard about the
ancient Japanese art of origami
it's paper folding using paper to create
beautiful objects we think that
potentially the person behind this took
the arts concept and it's something
rather different with it what they did
as you can see was to take the loo roll
and transform it into a face it's
actually quite a good face it looks to
be a young girl and they've even given
her plates we think that she looks
rather like Pippi Longstocking the
feisty young heroine of the classic
children's books by astrid lindgren
maybe that's who it was supposed to be
but what turns this from well that's
pretty cool - what the heck were they
doing is that this was in a public
restroom that's right
someone would have gone into a cubicle
and seen this staring up at them let's
face it that's one place where you don't
want to feel like someone's watching you
and there's one worrying question this
person bring it in with them or do they
just make it there and if it's the
latter just how long would they have
been in there for seven taking the tips
out of the strawberry how do you ever
eat miss strawberry we reckon you
probably have and if you have eaten them
you'll know that they are absolutely
delicious sweet succulent and juicy and
you know what even though they have
seeds you probably won't notice them
they aren't like blackberries or
raspberries those things make you want
to book a date with a toothbrush but you
know how you said you probably wouldn't
notice the Pips of a strawberry well it
looks like at least one person noticed
them have you seen these pictures or
indeed pictures someone has taken the
time to get a strawberry and then very
delicately taking the tips out of them
the thing is these things are tiny like
only a millimeter long and a fraction
wide and there are literally hundreds of
the little green things so unless this
person was some kind of toothpick ninja
it would have taken them absolutely ages
to do like it would have been quicker to
have eaten the strawberry if they were
that worried about getting something
caught between their teeth they could
have just brushed them we'll bet that
even if they had to go and get a
toothbrush and toothpaste
it would have taken them far far less
time than slowly and methodically
gouging out each fit you have to admire
this person's dedication but you also
have to ask
five six point spiral to nowhere
although we're living in a world where
it's more and more commonplace to pay by
a card or a phone cash is still used for
loads of things but one of the things
about using cash that ends up being a
little bit annoying is how much of it
can get stacked up it can really clog up
your pockets making it harder to get a
hold of your wallet now you could use
your change the next time you make a
purchase rather than breaking into
another notes or if you found yourself
with way too much time on your hands you
could do it this next person dip they
got their change all of the same kind of
coin and they stacked it up now a lot of
people do that because it makes it
easier to work out how much you have but
what a lot of people don't do is make a
pretty awesome kind of sculpture out of
them it's really rather wonderful it
looks like a piece of Modern Art or
possibly a strange kind of seashell or
maybe even a section of a staircase to
nowhere or even part of a DNA double
helix to be honest we aren't entirely
sure what it's supposed to be and we're
not entirely sure just how much is in
this cash sculpture or how long it would
have taken the person who made it to do
it but it looks good so that's cool
five-car covered in post-it notes
sometimes if you want to leave a message
a post-it note is a great idea it's
small it's easy to use and if you see
one you know something is written on it
and if you live in a place where it's
the law to have motor insurance they're
good to keep in your car if you
accidentally hit another vehicle you can
leave your detail so you can sort the
problem out later but check out this
picture this saloon car has been covered
entirely in post-it notes
and something tells us that this vehicle
has not been involved in a collision
well okay it might have been once maybe
but it couldn't have been involved in as
many pranks as there are notes on it we
think that there must be literally
hundreds if not thousands of the things
on there
and whoever it was that put in there
they made a very real effort to counter
they didn't just get one color
they got three their blue votes pink
notes and the traditional yellow notes
and they aren't put on or randomly and
higgledy-piggledy either the person who
must have had way too much time on their
hands created their own funky design
there's stripes on the sides the black
wheels are blue the front wheels are
blue and red and there's a cool
checkerboard design on the rear window
we don't know why someone did this but
it made us laugh four ball pit matching
bonanza when you were a kid did you love
playing in the ball pit we did it was
great fun you could chill out or swim
around or even throw the balls about
sometimes even had a slide to take you
in there but one thing it definitely
would have had was colored balls lots
and lots and lots of colored balls and
they would have all been a wide variety
of colors too but imagine is working on
a play center which had a ball pit and
imagine you worked really hard looking
after the kids and making sure
everything was safe and clean and well
and imagine that the place is too close
to the public for the day but you've got
lots of time left on your shift now
because you're diligent and
conscientious employees the venue
doesn't need much maintenance after
opening hours but you've got a lot of
time left before you can go home like a
lot of time left so what do you do well
we know what one person did they got all
the balls in the ball pit and they put
them together by color new mad
that reds oranges yellows greens blues
and purples all in different sectors of
the pen this must have taken forever and
after all that hard work do you think
the kids who used it the next day would
have kept it that way we don't but for
one note everything was together three
office doppelgänger have you ever worked
in an office we have and while I can
usually be pretty good there are times
when you just want to get out for a bit
whether it's you enjoy an unexpectedly
nice day grab something to eat or just
go home but a lot of the time you can't
you have to stay indoors doing your work
one thing you can pretty much guarantee
is that someone somewhere will notice
you're gone what can make it even worse
is when that someone is your boss then
you can really get in trouble you might
end up losing your job and no one wants
that
so what do you do if you want to head
out it's a puzzler but with one person
who really weren't to get some fresh air
had was a great idea a great idea and
oddly enough a lot of time first of all
he got a whole load of plastic cups from
the water cooler then he got some sticky
tape after that he made arms legs and a
torso from the cups he placed him on the
chair and you want to know why we're
calling this person he well it's because
they drew a face on their fake class
exam leaving him glasses and the pretty
cool goatee beard the very best thing is
that this guy must have been a great
worker to have so much time to do it
we hope you got promoted to a cat in a
flame if you have a pass through the
chances are you'll do pretty much
anything for them having an animal to
look after and become friends with is
something that can bring a lot of joy to
your existence and you'll want to do
your best to make life great for your
furry companion but someone took things
a bit too far what they did was make
this admittedly mind-blowing plain for
their cat yes that's right a plane with
Queens and everyday
we don't know how long it would have
taken them but they probably didn't have
much else on that day for days it's kind
of like an old-fashioned Second World
War era contraption
it's got checks on the front at the edge
of the wings it's got a pretty sweet
looking for power at the nose and the
wings are paying to the very military
battleships shade of grey it looks
really really good but we aren't
entirely sure what it would be used for
the cockpit where you see the cat
sitting looks a bit too small for her to
curl up into an estate we all know how
much cats need space right and wouldn't
have been easier to get the kitty a nice
basket from a pet store but when you see
the look on this cat's face you'd think
it was worth it one a room covered in
duct tape sometimes playing pranks can
be kind of funny we know that it can
seem a little bit infantile but it can
make us laugh and those of us with
brothers and sisters know that winding
our siblings up is incredibly satisfying
so that's why one guy did this to his
brother only you'd wonder how he managed
to find the time to do such a thing
Jake Paul who also found fame as a
YouTube video blogger found himself with
not much to do one day so in keeping
with his smart aleck wisecracking
prankster persona he did something crazy
he'll wind up his brother Logan he
decided to duct-tape
Logan's bedroom now we aren't talking
about putting a few strips of the
material over the door or on the
wardrobe here know what Jake Paul did
was get a ridiculously large amount of
duct tape and slathered all over poor
Logan groom understandably his brother
was more than a little bit upset by what
Jake had done pretty much every inch was
covered so understandably Jake his
friends and the millions of people who
followed Jake on YouTube found it rather
amusing we'd like to know how Jake Paul
who's evidently a very busy guy found
the time to cover Logan's brew
in deaf safe and where did he get it
from we'd also love to know what have
you done when you had way too much time
on your hands let us know in the
comments that's all for our ten people
who had way too much time on their hands
if you liked it check out 10 toys that
weren't supposed to be for kids thanks
for watching and make sure to subscribe
to the things
[Music]